[Musique]
non
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire la fermeture des restaurants
bars et cafés d'aix en provence et de
marseille est effective depuis hier soir
minuit
la fronde des élus et des restaurateurs
marseillais n'est parvenu qu'à reculer
l'échéance de 48 heures est aujourd'hui
un restaurant sur le vieux port qui
prétendait braver l'interdiction a vu
débarquer en plein déjeuner les crs et
la police nationale il a dû fermer son
établissement sur le champ mais d'autres
ont prévenu que si d'ici huit jours
on ne laissait pas ouvrir normalement
jusqu'à 2 heures du matin ils se
mettraient d'accord et le ferai quand
même alors nous voilà face à une
nouvelle manifestation des relations pas
toujours facile qu'entretiennent paris
et la province paris et marseille en
particulier
ou bien s'agit-il d'un exemple
supplémentaire de la crise de confiance
que connaît notre pays à l'égard de ses
dirigeants et que la crise du comique 19
n'a fait qu'amplifier encore davantage
pour en débattre nous avons invité hervé
le bras ce démographe historien
chercheur émérite à l'institut national
d'études démographiques directeur
d'études à l'école des hautes études en
sciences sociales
vous êtes auteur entre autres de
l'invention de la france et du mystère
français de livre coécrit avec emmanuel
todd
mais aussi de malaise dans l'identité
chez actes sud
comment analysez-vous en deux mots on va
en parler pendant toute l'émission
comment analysez vous ce qui se passe en
ce moment entre marseille et la capitale
ou plutôt entre marseille et le
gouvernement hervé le bras je trouve que
ça illustre une difficulté qui est dans
cette affaire de contrôle de l'épidémie
d'un côté il faut protéger les personnes
donc les marseillais mais aussi il faut
protéger ce que la contamination de ma
de marseille peut atteindre c'est à dire
des régions qui sont beaucoup moins
atteintes l'aspect géographique est
extrêmement important donc on arrive on
a beaucoup de mal à régler ces deux
questions
dans le cas de du confinement on les
avait réglé ensemble c'est à dire que on
avait empêché les déplacements et on
avait obligé les personnes à un endroit
donné de rester à l'intérieur de leur
logement
là maintenant on peut bien sûr eurent
recours
fini donc le problème est comment éviter
que à la fois les marseillais se sentent
forcée par l'état central mais en même
temps que les marseillais par leurs
déplacements s'ils décident de
s'organiser le même par leurs
déplacements contaminent d'autres
parties de la france c'est le problème
qui est souvent ignorée bienvenue martin
vous êtes politologues sociologues
chercheuse en sciences politiques à la
quête jeu business school à marseille
vous êtes l'auteur de talent gâché le
coût de la discrimination et de ce monde
qui nous échappe pour un universalisme
des différences de livre paru aux
éditions de l'aube
comment analysez vous la réaction des
des marseillais en tout cas d'un certain
nombre de marseillais dans cette affaire
bah disons marseille comme souvent est
un peu j'allais dire à la pointe d'une
forme de radicalité politique et ça
c'est quand même intéressant c'est pas
non plus une ville que je voudrais un
caricaturé par mon propos c'est aussi
une ville complexe mais hervé lebras
parlé tout à l'heure de géographie ne
faut pas oublier aussi que marseille par
sa géographie regarde vers le sud
en définitive donc de côté afrique en
définitive elle ne regarde pas paris
donc c'est une vie quelque part qui est
déjà aux marches un petit peu du pays
par sa géographie
mais après elle se vit aussi très
souvent comme marginal un petit peu
radicale et souvent elle est à la pointe
de quelque chose en définitive qui va de
toute façon après comme cela si miss est
un petit peu partout donc sans
caricaturer cette ville
elle est quand même aussi à l'appoint
d'une certaine forme de radicalité et on
le voyait aussi évidemment son rapport
paris le rapport paris marseille n'est
plus à à développer ici chacun le
connaît il ya ça aussi dans cette ville
plus particulièrement françois cocq est
enseignant vous avez été l'un des
fondateurs du parti de gauche l'un des
dirigeants de la france a soumises que
vous avez quitté en 2010
8 vous êtes l'auteur de l'impératif
démocratique de la crise de la
représentativité au gilet jaune et de
retraite impasse et perspectives avec
sacha me critiquent les deux sont parus
aux éditions du borrego comment analysez
vous la réaction marseillaise la
décision d'olivier ferrand je trouve que
leur réaction des marseillais et des
marseillais est finalement sans surprise
et 7 conflictuelle it est naissante
aujourd'hui tient beaucoup à
l'incohérence de la politique du
gouvernement qui ne peut pas être
comprise en l'état quand on fait preuve
d'autoritarisme
plutôt que de poser un cadre national un
cadre global qui permettrait que les
décisions retombées soient acceptées un
petit peu partout sur l'ensemble du
territoire d'une certaine façon
depuis quelques semaines on a vu que
monsieur macron pratiquer la politique
de la défausse et cette politique de la
défausse s'est traduite par un gironde
isme sanitaires et les conséquences de
ce gérant 10e sanitaire aujourd'hui
c'est qu'elles ne feront dans l'est dans
les territoires à commencer par
marseille
georges e cristiani enfin vous êtes
président des maires des bouches du
rhône
mi mai est une ville de 5000 habitants
dont vous êtes le maire et mime et s'est
retrouvée le 14 septembre sur la liste
des 27 communes où le port du masque
devenait obligatoire alors qu'aucun cas
de kevin n'avait été porté à votre
connaissance
en fait c'était une erreur mais c'est la
preuve d'après vous que le durcissement
des mesures sanitaires s'effectue sans
concertation c'est comme ça que vous
expliquer la la fronde des marseillais
comme on l'appelait
c'est peut-être une fronde qui se
comprend dans la mesure où le premier
ministre et le président de république
nous indique que quelques quelques jours
avant que les décisions se prendraient
en concertation avec les élus locaux et
nous apprenons par monsieur le ministre
de la santé que cette concertation en
fait n'est pas du tout une mais c'est
une décision verticale qui nous impose d
d d d d interdiction qui à notre sens
locaux sont disproportionnées donc
à partir du moment qu'il y à une
association non concertation et qu'il y
à un compréhension il ya deux façons de
deux risager chose swahili à soumission
soit il y a
révolte et je dirais colère donc on est
dans cette situation
dans une ville comme marseille et 92
communes car il ne s'agit pas uniquement
de marseille il s'agit de la métropole
de marseille qui compte 92 communes et
je le rappelle 92 communes baignée par
la méditerranée dans une métropole qui
se veut être une métropole monde n'est
pas du tout renfermé sur nous-mêmes mais
bien au contraire au nez au niveau d'une
ouverture
alors commençons ce débat les
marseillais ont parlé de punition
collective de discrimination ils ont dit
deux poids deux mesures provocation il
ya eu des appels à la désobéissance
civile
est ce que tout ce tous ces mots étaient
mérités change cristiani d'ailleurs les
mots il y à des faits derrière les mots
il y a une vie et au delà des cif camp
nou camp le serine à longueur de journée
par par des déclarations ou des
communications de l'état il y a chez
nous des gens qui vivent donc il y a
quand même un million huit cent mille
habitants qui sont frappés à un moment
donné par une annonce médiatique très
bien médiatisé d'ailleurs qui fait qu'il
ya une incompréhension totale donc sage
est de l'angoisser que ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure et donc on arrive
à 7
cette idée qui est ce qui ce qui est
très bien sous titré dans votre dans
votre émission c'est à dire marseille ou
trajet marseille mater risée mais
j'espère marseille concertée on va
discuter avec elle on doit discuter avec
marseille et les 92 communes qui
composent la métropole de marseille on
ne peut pas continuer à avoir comme cela
un état jacobin qui nous qui nous impose
sans eau sans vraiment la connaissance
des chances de chez nous qui nous
imposent les directives et nous
mozac nous assomme d'interdiction ça ne
peut pas continuer comme ça et il y a un
autre effet chez nous avec qui on doit
travailler et ce préfet est ma foi
j'espère qu'il doit être entendu au
niveau national peut pas continuer comme
ça mais le préfet c'est le représentant
de l'état dans les régions c'est pas
leurs représentants des régions auprès
de l'état alors effectivement vous avez
présenté le mot c'est un état jacobin
alors c'est vrai que ça revient on en
reparlera hervé le bras ce tous ces mots
que je citais punition que les teams
discrimination deux poids deux mesures
c'est hervé le bras ça vous semble pas
justifier un bon jeu c'était que c'est
c'est certainement excessif c'est
surtout très peu si l'on peut dire
programmatique c'est à dire je crois que
comme je les ai dit au début il ya deux
questions à régler il ya la protection
des marseillais eux mêmes comment
peut-on maîtriser cette épidémie qui est
plus forte à marseille qu'ailleurs
et ça je pense effectivement que c'est
une question qui regarde les marseillais
mais il ya le protection aussi et ça
c'est le souci de l'état du reste des
français et la de ce point de vue là ça
regarde complètement l'état une solution
bien sûr possible
et après tout c'est celle qui a été
adoptée ya maintenant assez longtemps
puisque c'était lors de la grande peste
de marseille 2721 ça consiste à entourer
marseille d'une ce qu'on appelait une
ligne à l'époque donc à contrôler les
entrées sorties de marseille et puis a
laissé les marseillais en les aidant
financièrement et aussi avec tout ce qui
est bien sûr les approvisionnements les
laisser gérer eux mêmes la leur maladie
c'est ça le souci de l'état c'est que
cinq sets en deux temps c'est un souci
général qui est très difficile à régler
mais qu'on est arrivé à régler dans la
première vague a été au prix vous le
savez une confinement donc là on a
appliqué deux jacobinisme un jacobinisme
qui empêchait les personnes de circuler
sur le territoire et puis un autre qui
les obligeait à rester chez elle je
crois que tu montes peut pas faire cela
c'est un hobby nisme au fort il a fait
ses preuves mais il est beaucoup plus et
il est excessif à ce moment là
faudrait justement discuter des moyens à
la fois de laisser les marseillais assez
libres de leur destin mais d'empêcher
d'une certaine manière que ce qui se
passe à marseille
employant le mot contamine et régions
qui sont beaucoup moins atteintes par le
virus
françois cocq marseille vous semble
méritée comme cela un sort particulier
ne serait ce que parce que ses habitants
ou en tout cas ces lignes pourraient
contaminer davantage le reste de la
france
écoutez la compétence sanitaire est une
compétence nationale et c'est une bonne
chose parce que c'est celle qui garantit
l'égalité de tous devant la loi et un
égal traitement de tous ça veut dire
bien sûr que le cadre national nous
permet de penser l'épidémie et la
circulation de l'épidémie et de la
juguler mais c'est aussi au national et
à l'état à l'ensemble du pays de prendre
en charge la vie des marseillais et des
marseillais et ne pas le laisser seul et
démuni face à ce virus
de ce point de vue là il n'y a pas un
état jacobin qui devrait prendre soin
des autres et mettre à part une partie
du territoire il doit prendre soin de
tous le problème c'est que pour ce faire
il ya besoin d'un cadrage d'un cadrage
global de règles qui sont donnés et qui
sont édictées en fonction justement des
priorités sanitaires qui sont fixés
grâce à tous les relever que
2 que le ministère à sa disposition sauf
qu'on n'a vu depuis quelques semaines et
que les préfets et ils étaient
d'ailleurs les premiers à s'en plaindre
alors of bien sûr parce que vous savez
que les préfets peuvent pas dire les
choses
face caméra mais on a vu dans la presse
que les préfets se plaignaient de ne pas
avoir de directive et c'est pour ça
qu'on a vu des directives et des mesures
qui étaient prises différentes d'un
endroit à l'autre vous savez vous avez
vu ce qui se passait par exemple avec
l'affluence dans les stades de foot qui
étaient 2000 un endroit de 6500 un autre
dérogation accordée d'autres qui ne
l'étaient pas et on se retrouve
aujourd'hui dans cette même situation
finalement d'un point de vue sanitaire
et l'état après avoir laissé aller
pendant des semaines décide de taper du
poing sur la table et il le fait c'est
vrai d'une manière extrêmement brutal à
marseille où les choses ont sont
difficilement comprise puisque il ya des
efforts qui avait déjà été fait et que
l'épidémie était sinon en cours de
résorption du moins était en phase
d'atténuation donc je comprends que les
marseillais et les marseillais aient du
mal à faire face à cette situation est
assez à ses réponses qui apparaissent
brutale et martin vous aussi vous
trouvez que il y avait deux poids deux
mesures qu'on a peut-être exagéré avec
les marseillais
je ne sais pas s'il ya deux poids deux
mesures dont la mesure justement où les
choses ne sont pas très claires au fait
lors des conférences de presse et
notamment la dernière d'olivier les
rangs c'est une espèce de litanie qui se
veut extrêmement pédagogique extrêmement
explicative
mais qui finit en fait dans le vide
absolu politique et c'est un instant
nous aurait dit michel foucault
biopolitique un cette politique qui doit
là aujourd'hui maximiser nos vies faire
en sorte que la vie continue
du mieux possible et pour tous et pour
tous c'est ça cet instant biopolitique
mais cet instant biopolitique est
extrêmement mal géré il est mal gérée
depuis janvier il a été mal gérée
pendant confinement il a été très mal
gérée pendant déconfinement puis après
il ya une espèce de d'appel d'air
d'oxygène pendant les vacances ou tout
d'un coup plus rien ne comptait et on
aurait dit qu'il n'y avait plus de
coronavirus et pour reparler de
marseille tout le monde se gausser ils
se réjouissent et des plus 30 % de
tourisme à marseille est plus dure sera
la chute est plus dure est la chute
aujourd'hui de manière comme ça comme un
couperet qui tombe donc je ne dis pas
que ce n'est pas la bonne solution je
n'en sais absolument rien je ne suis pas
là pour ça et je ne suis pas si ça te va
partie de mon champ de compétence ce que
je vois c'est qu'en revanche il ya des
incohérences il ya cet instant
biopolitique est extrêmement mal gérée
extrêmement mal géré et donc plus il est
mal gérée plus évidemment les révoltes
se font entendre
elles se font entendre à marseille
aujourd'hui de manière vraiment très
forte
mais les derniers sondages aujourd'hui
sont catastrophiques pour justement au
regard de cette gestion qui est de toute
façon chaotique est catastrophique et
son cap d'une certaine manière dont alex
que raconte marcel ne révèle que ça en
fait
arrêtons nous un instant sol et les
rapports un peu particulier que
marseille entretien avec eux avec la
capitale celle-ci était déjà rebeller en
1794 contre le comité de salut public
qu'elle trouvait trop centralisateur et
elle avait été sanctionné pendant
quelques mois elle était devenue la la
ville sans nous on le voit d'ailleurs
marseille s'en souvient très bien quand
il parle de marseille aux révolutions
ils se souviennent que là on avait
débaptisé marseille c'était la ville son
nom on se souvient également qu'en 1939
suite à un grave incendie
à marseille on avait carrément mis
marseille sous tutelle le le maire à
l'époque avait été remplacé par un
administrateur nommé en conseil des
ministres qui avait hérité de tous les
pouvoirs du maire c'est à dire les
pouvoirs administratifs et les et les
pouvoirs de police
donc tout ça est et dans une histoire
qui est quand même entre marseille et
paris alors qu'ils passent ensuite par
le football
pas toutes sortes de choses mais hervé
le bras ce comment vous expliquez ce
rapport particulier de marseille allait
à la capitale je pense aussi qu'ils à
marseille et à une structure très
particulière du point de vue de sape de
sa population
vous avez la population de paris à paris
intra muros disons c'est des bourgeois
et puis vous vous éloignez plus vous
avez des classes populaires
a marseille c'est un ensemble c'est à
dire que les classes populaires sont à
l'intérieur de marseille n'est si l'on
peut dire en termes parisien les
banlieues sont dans marseille qui fait
qu' on a un terreau tout à fait
particulier qui est d'ailleurs très
démocratique cerib sociologue
marseillais un criminologue marseillais
par exemple à montrer que quand on
compare la criminalité à marseille et à
paris on fait une très grosse erreur il
faut comptable on part et la criminalité
à marseille et à l'ensemble
au moins de paris et les trois
départements de petite couronne et à ce
moment là on arrive à peu près au même
résultat alors que bien sûr si on prend
paris tous se lèvent paris a l'air
d'être supérieur en sécurité de
marseille donc il ya un problème qui
tout à fait spécifique et qui fait qu'il
ya une sorte d'incompréhension
on peut pas comparer marseille et paris
il faut comparer marseille avec à une
grande région parisienne
avec l'os parce que je m'arrête à la
petite couronne mais il faut aussi la
dépasser et prendre presque la moitié de
l'île de france
mais genre cristiani là quand marseille
se rebelle
on l'a vu ça s'est arrêté très vite pour
l'instant il ya des menaces sur la suite
mais chacun est devenu très obéissante
pour l'instant mais néanmoins quand
marcel rebelles ont dit bars ils se
rebellent contre paris mais la roue du
carrosse pas contre paris c'est contre
le gouvernement il se trouve que le
gouvernement est à paris mais le
gouvernement représente l'ensemble des
français ça n'est pas ça n'est pas une
émanation parisienne
la seule grande ville qui ce soit ma
connaissance historiquement réellement
dresser contre le paris depuis la
république c'est paris pendant la
commune qui s'est dressé contre le
gouvernement qualifié de versailles est
en 1871
mais c'est la seule fois où il ya eu
véritablement un séparatisme on n'en est
pas là à marseille mais mais comment
expliquez-vous historiquement ce rapport
conflictuel entre marseille et est la
capitale c'est très simple c'est très
simple on part du principe que de paris
se dirige la france en verticalité
on part du principe que depuis
robespierre qui a fait décapiter les
girondins parce qu'il voulait être que
les parisiens représente 1 83e dollars à
l'assemblée n'a posé on a fait
exactement la même chose pourtant encore
si là il voulait être enterré sur les
rives de la seine du peuple qui lie
l'état et petit à petit on s'est bien
rendu compte que paris dirigeant la
france mais vu d'en haut
il a bien fallu que quelques hommes
d'état et si je me souviens bien le
général de gaulle à un moment donné
disait que la force venaient des régions
est un peu plus près de nous monsieur
mitterrand disait que la france a eu
besoin d'un pouvoir fort pour se bâtir
mais également elle a besoin de pouvoir
décentralisé pour ne pas se défaire dans
les zones d'état quel qu'il soit se sont
rendus compte qu'un moment donné
la france était trop centralisée donc si
on reste dans cette situation
ça y est un nom pas éloigné à l'heure
des clics de souris
à l'heure d'internet on n'est pas du
tout éloigné c'est pas cela mais un ici
il ya une terre il y a du sens et c'est
pas simplement la ville de marseille
c'est la province tout entière qui est
ainsi constitué il ne faut pas imaginer
qu'il y ait des rebelles provençaux et
qu'il y ait d'autres provinces qui soit
beaucoup plus obéissante ce n'est pas le
cas nos paris 4e il faut pas caricaturer
tout ça où on est dans une situation
aujourd'hui où nous sommes agressés
parce qu'il nous est interdite d'exister
comment voulez vous que nous comprenions
l'état d'esprit de du gouvernement
lorsque d'un côté ils nous donnent des
contraventions
ils donnent des contraventions aux
français qui ne porte pas ce qu'ils sont
incapables de nous fournir des masques
l'autre côté ils nous disent les masques
il faut pas importer parce que c'est
dangereux ensuite les masses que lui
porte et laisser mieux on est dans une
contradiction totale qu'on peut
comprendre par rapport à un virus qui
est un virus qu'on connaît mal et on
peut comprendre que cela soit difficile
mais surtout on se rend compte que la
france dirigée depuis paris n'était pas
prête à assumer cette crise à partir de
ce moment là lorsque la confiance se
tord lorsque le gouvernement national
parisien qui se doit d'être d'être
d'être rigoureux dans cette dans cette
crise sanitaire
comment voulez vous qu ensuite les
programmes de la cobas et les provinces
puissent accepter cela donc il ne s'agit
pas d'une dune d'un affrontement entre
la province et la ville de marseille et
ses 92 communes j'y tiens parce que
c'est pas que la ville de marseille
c'est le 92 communes de la métropole de
marseille comment voulez vous que l'on
puisse ne pas être assez roux trajet
dans cette façon de procéder donc ce
qu'il faut c'est surtout pas considérer
que nous sommes des révoltés et que nous
n'acceptons plus aucune aucune directive
de l'état bien au contraire
nous respectons la loi et nous
continuerons la respective mais à un
moment donné il ne faut plus que l'état
imagine pouvoir diriger la france avec
une une conception qu'ils ont de voir la
france d'un satellite
la france se sont constitués de de gens
qui vivent et ce n'est pas que des
chiffres à partir de ce2 de ce constat
là on ne doit pas moi je me permets de
vous dire plutôt que de considérer une
rivalité qui serait historique ou
ancestral à notre époque on ne peut pas
aller jusque là
on dit simplement que l'on se doit en
france et surtout de la nation pour que
ça constitue bien cette nation et non
pas simplement un hexagone
il faut que dans cette nation il y ait
un état qui respecte les territoires
qu'ils comprennent bien que la terre que
les humaines ont une valeur ce ne sont
pas que des chiffres et à partir de ce
moment là
cet état centralisé comprendra que ce
déficit qui qui qui qui hélas ce déficit
démocratique est en fait un déficit
qu'humanitaire tout simplement donc il
faut qu'à un moment donné les dirigeants
s'appuie aussi sur les communes sur les
départements et sur les régions en soi
coque vous aviez l'air de dire que
l'état est obligé d'avoir une politique
très centralisatrice en matière
sanitaire
en fait il peut pas tellement car il
peut pas tellement être ceux il peut il
peut y est payant à la concertation
n'est pas forcément une entente mais je
vous écoute oui c'est pas forcément ça
qu'ils jouent mais d'abord un mot si
vous permettez monsieur taddei pour
rendre marseillais quand même ce qu'il a
ce qui leur appartient il ya eu la
commune de paris en 1871
mais marseille a connu aussi comme
d'autres villes des épisodes communards
important ils en ont eu même de en 1870
et 1871
mais pour revenir à ce moment de
confiture alité actuelle entre marseille
et paris je crois que ça ne nous en dit
pas tant sur le rapport de marseille à
paris que sur le rapport de paris et du
gouvernement à marseille
ce que je veux dire par là c'est qu'il
ya dix jours vous en souvenez il ya eu
une conférence de presse
un mercredi soir où olivier vers ans
était attendu et finalement nous avons
eu monsieur castex pourquoi parce que
lors du conseil des ministres le matin
olivier ferrand s'est fait taper sur les
doigts par le chef de l'état et on
s'attendait à ce qu'il y ait des mesures
sanitaires qui soient annoncées il ya
dix jours au lieu de ça rien rien du
tout
comme si la vague n'était pas en train
de grossir et monsieur castex a
simplement finalement annoncé le
raccourcissement de la durée de
quarantaine de deux semaines à une
semaine donc c'était même une forme
d'assouplissement des règles
sauf que la vague est là la vague et le
gouvernement ont été rattrapés par la
marée d'une certaine façon et le
gouvernement a donc dû faire d'une
certaine façon un exemple et puisqu'il
avait dit depuis le début qu'il n'y
aurait pas de reconfirme en généraliser
il fallait bien trouver un endroit où
faire acte d'autorité d'autoritarisme
même comme on l'a vu
et cet endroit était finalement tout
trouvé marseille parce que effectivement
cet été il ya une forte affluence
touristique que de fait les conditions
sanitaires etc sont aussi compliquées à
marseille depuis de nombreuses semaines
et puis peut-être parce que qui sait
monsieur macron à quelques
arrière-pensées électoralistes et que
marseille et sa métropole ne sont
finalement pas un terrain de conquête
pour lui dans l'est dans les mois à
venir pour les élections départementales
et régionales
au regard des difficultés de son
mouvement il ya peut-être bien des
considérations politiques politiciennes
qui se mêle aussi à cette décision que
nous avons connues on s'interrompt un
instant on fait une pause on se retrouve
juste après et on continue ce débat avec
avec virginie martin
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'une entreprise zone des
entreprises que l'on maintient sous
perfusion combien sont-elles vous savez
plein d'entreprises aujourd'hui qui sont
des entreprises zombies et y en a plein
qui vont le devenir avec les mesures qu
on est en train de prendre ce qu'il
aurait fallu faire dès le départ c'était
être capable d'analyser les plis dans
des entreprises pour savoir lesquelles
elle souffrait simplement du confinement
ou de du ralentissement de l'activité et
les qu'elle était déjà en état de deux
morts avancé on est en train de tuer
l'économie et vous avez une façon de
relancer l'économie qui est beaucoup
plus saine que ce qui est annoncé là et
qui évite ce genre de problème c'est de
baisser les impôts de production besson
les impôts sur les entreprises qui
marchent et donc qui font du résultat
celles qui sont déjà son billet elles
font pas de résultat donc vous pouvez
baisser les impôts vous n'allez pas leur
donner de l'argent en fait
[Musique]
14 juillet 2015 et signé à vienne un
accord de limitation du nucléaire
iranien à sa partie purement civil
contrairement aux engagements de
l'accord signé et respecté par les
iraniens
le président entre hommes avaient décidé
de rompre l'accord et d'imposer son
régime de sanctions au niveau
international sur 1000 iran en grave
difficulté au plan économique et social
pour la chine c'est une très belle
opportunité
la première question qu'il faut se poser
est lourde de conséquences les iraniens
avaient ils un autre choix face aux
pressions américaines en tous genres par
notre incapacité à répondre à ces
attentes légitimes ne les avons pas
pousser dans les bras d'un partenaire
qui va en profiter pour faire de l'iran
sa tête de pont au moyen-orient
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat avec hervé le bras
ce qui est démographe et historien avec
virginie martin qui peut lutter log et
sociologue avec françois cocq qui est
enseignant et georges christian dit
qu'il président des maires du
département des bouches du rhône vient
gély martin vous le disais au début de
cette émission marseille est souvent l
avant-garde certaine radicalité
ça voudrait dire que cette radicalité
pourrait s'étendre alors qu est il
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup parlé de la
crise de confiance à l'égard de nos
dirigeants qui se serait amplifiée
depuis le début du corps année virus ce
serait ça qui se traduirait la réaction
et des restaurateurs des cafetiers mais
aussi des élus marseillais on aurait de
moins en moins confiance dont nous
dirigeants et c'est ça qu'il manifestait
oui de toute façon on voit clairement
dans l'est dans les derniers sondages
d'opinion qu'on peut avoir
on voit très bien que les pourcentages
de gens qui soutiennent le gouvernement
et qui lui pardonne ses errances ce
pourcentage s'amenuise de jour en jour
pendons justement ce mois de septembre
qui ressemble à une deuxième bague
évidemment donc il y avait au début de
l'année 2020 quelques légitimiste qui
disait bon après tout c'est vrai qu'on
n'est pas très bien préparés ne peut pas
tout prévoir
voilà l'anticipation n'a pas été fait et
c'est rare et quelques gîtes i missed
pardonner à ce gouvernement par donner
malgré agnès buzyn malgré six bêtes
hendaia et c'est pardonné mais là
aujourd'hui même ceux de la première
heure qui soutenait emmanuel macron
notamment lors du premier tour et
deuxième tour de la présidentielle 2010
elle même cela en fait que son socle
d'électeurs commence à s'émousser est à
dire dans certaines dents certains
verbatim qu'il navigue à vue et que
vraiment ils ne savent pas où ils vont
alors évidemment ça c'est très fort chez
les électeurs de la france insoumise
chez les au rassemblement national mais
aussi au ps très fortement aussi chez
les as l'air donc on voit bien que ce
mouvement est en train de s'étendre et
finalement c'est pour ça que j'ai envie
de dire que marseille c'est un peu une
fonction sémaphorique vous voyez un peu
à l'avant garde finalement de cette
radicalité est un révélateur
par ailleurs aussi juste une dernière
phrase peut-être sur marseille aussi
qu'il faut peut-être mieux comprendre
dans sa complexité
alors c'est une ville extrêmement
étendue mais qui est aussi une terre
d'asile séculaire et marseille donc à
une identité très forte et si vous
voulez quand on demande aux gens qu
est-ce qui calait leur identité d'où
qu'ils viennent
ils mettent souvent l'identité
marseillaise avant l'identité ou de leur
pays d'origine où l'identité française
ou quoique ce soit d'autre
donc c'est très intéressant marseille
aussi à ce pouvoir de créer l'identité
de fer homogénéité au sein même de ses
murs hervé le bras ce oui non là je suis
tout à fait d'accord sur cette question
d'identité mais il me semble que dans
cette discussion
au fond on mélange de choses qui sont
très différentes qui sont la question
d'épidémie comment traiter l'épidémie et
puis la question du centralisme et au
fond cette question l'épidémie était le
plus mauvais moyen de poser la question
du centre alsace et frais comme ça mais
là il ya et suis d'accord à deux points
de vue avec françois cocq en matière de
sanitaires dans des cas aussi urgent
nécessairement il ya une part de
jacobinisme ceci dit si on prend l'autre
question celle du centralisme là je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec force qu avec
georges cristiani c'est un véritable
problème les lois de décentralisation
ont toujours été en trompe l'oeil quand
on regarde dans le détail et on n'est
jamais arrivé au fond il ya cette
conception de la loi qui doit
s'appliquer également sur le territoire
est une conception républicaine
mais en réalité des territoires sont
extrêmement différents économique en
sociologiquement et à ce moment là il
faudrait qu'il y ait au fond
réglementaire beaucoup plus large qui
soit accordée aux communautés
territoriales on bute en permanence là
dessus et on a dès qu'il ya un peu de
type avancées en ce sens là on se prend
le conseil d'état qui interdit au
mouvement le faire la décentralisation
quand on regarde de de près parce que
c'est au fond lui qui tient l'armature
d'état assez assez largement avec son
pouvoir pratiquement légale response
tant sur les aspects sanitaires du
problème vous le disiez hervé le bras ce
vous faites partie et françois cau qosi
qui pensent que c'est le plan sanitaire
c'est à l'état la centralisation a une
raison d'être et settat et il faut
prendre une décision et ça doit venir
d'en haut
néanmoins on peut avoir l'impression je
me mets à la place des ddd restaurateur
marseillais et pas seulement de
versailles et d'autres restaurateurs en
france et à paris compris vont doit
fermer à 22h par exemple on se met à
leur place et îlots revivre ce lien mais
pourquoi nous quoi pourquoi les
restaurateurs ils ont fait non seulement
les a fermés pendant les deux ou trois
mois de confinement mais en plus fallu
que ça ait duré trois mois en plus ils
ont fait exactement ce qu'on leur a dit
néanmoins le virus quand il circulait ce
qui était une évidence
personne n'avait dit qu'il avait arrêté
de circuler donc ils continuent de
circuler et on leur dit que c'est de
votre faute en gros il faut fermer tout
ça alors pourquoi eux pourquoi les
salles de sport pourquoi pas les écoles
pourquoi pas les entreprises
on voit bien qu'il ya un moment il faut
décider que c'est là et pas ailleurs et
ça peut sembler tout simplement injuste
et on peut avoir l'impression aussi que
c'est parce que le gouvernement s'est
peut-être trompé avec les tests avec
l'application
c'est peut-être pas aussi efficace que
ce que l'on avait dit les tests sap tout
est mis trop longtemps on n'a pas isoler
les cas contacts on n'a pas isolé les
gens qui avaient le crâné virus et bien
que c'est peut-être là que ça se passe
et pas dans les restaurants par exemple
y avait le bras ce parce qu'on est ce
que c'est vous
le problème c'est le point c'est que
pour arrêter l'épidémie
il faut arrêter il faut essayer de
contrôler
les lieux où elles se propagent en had
évident on l'a vu dans en france
spécialement mais dans un certain nombre
de pays c'est l'émoi de nuit par exemple
donc là faut dire il ya le fermer les
routes de nuit que oui on a oui mais
s'ils ont au fond ce qu on pourrait
reprocher de plus au gouvernement c'est
pas simplement un manque de pédagogie
alors j'ai plaidé pour ma paroisse une
certaine manière c'est un manque de
sciences sociales c'est-à-dire de ne pas
avoir assez étudié les conditions
exactes dans lesquelles la transmission
se perde pas par exemple avoir mesuré
très justement dans les restaurants dans
les boîtes de nuit dans un certain
nombre dans les salles de sport
quelle est la distance minimale on sait
que cette distance minimale joue un rôle
très important de ne pas non plus avoir
fait assez attention au port du masque
quand il est recommandé
les marseillais s'insurge mais les
français dont les parisiens ceinture
d'une autre manière quand vous prenez
dans la rue à paris un certain nombre de
personnes n'ont pas de masque sait pas
où il ya une loi il n'y a pas de loi
d'une certaine manière mais
effectivement on n'a pas les données qui
pour qui permettre de bien comprendre
comment socialement ça se passe il n'a
pas cherché très fortement à recueillir
ces données alors que les données
médicales par contre les progrès qui
sont faits en termes de médicaments les
progrès qui sont faits la marche vers le
vaccin on est abondamment nourri en
information à ce sujet là mais sur la
faune la mécanique simple de la
contagion on a très peu de choses c'est
pour cela je crois que un doute c'est
beaucoup installé sur le traitement de
cette épidémie dont spéciales et cham
chez taddeï et chers collègues
conférencier avec nous j'avais
l'autorité d'un chef d'état ou d'un
premier ministre n'est pas le
ce ne ne l'autorisent pas à régner sur
la population pour la rendre obéissante
une autorité l'autorité n'est de la
confiance qu'il suscite auprès des gens
qui vivent sur le territoire dans les
lieux à la charge
c'est ce que nous faisons nous dans nos
communes moi je crois que passer par la
case élus de terrain et une nécessité
qui 2 pour comprendre les la population
j'ai vu j'ai lu quelques quelques
difficultés à faire comprendre à
quelques grands énarque ce qu'était la
vie de terrain pourtant il ya des bosses
auteurs comme camus jaune orwell qui ont
qui ont bien à célébrer la vie ordinaire
déjà en face aux grandes aux grandes
parisien pétri d'abstention je me rends
bien compte qu'ils lui que le président
de la république est un président aux
pieds d'argile parce qu'il n'a pas le
territoire en lui donc si on continue à
ne pas voir que dans cette crise
sanitaire qui dit qui est extrêmement
dangereuse nous ne sommes pas en
capacité en ai vu de l'état avait outre
seuls 7 cette crise on va se tromper
donc cette crise sanitaire qui est là
doit être pourrons pour nous un élément
de de sagesse on doit apaiser les choses
on doit travailler avec les élus locaux
et et d'entendre imaginer que marseille
serait la rebelle qui n'a pas compris
que la crise sanitaire est allée g
c'est une erreur donc il y a pas que la
ville de marseille d'ailleurs qui est
concerné par ces interdictions ya aussi
larry le texte la ville
d'aix-en-provence ex la romaine ou
marseille la grecque
c'est aussi des communes où il ya une
vraie identité forte
mais aussi des gens qui souffrent il ya
des restaurateurs en ce moment qu'ils
sont en train de mettre la clé sous la
porte
il ya des gens et à des fournisseurs de
restaurants qui aujourd'hui sont en
difficulté donc à un moment donné dire
les jeunes vous pouvez aller au cinéma
mais après vous pouvez pas aller boire
un coup au café du coin
franchement ça règle sa règle pas
ça ne réglera jamais c'est comme
d'ailleurs quand on autorise les
mariages mais qu'on dit après il faut
pas et danser c'est la même chose la
même caricature
donc à un moment donné si on ne comprend
pas si on comprend pas cela si on ne
comprend pas que il faut travailler avec
les provençaux avec des marseillais les
exploits et les 90 autres communes
on va pas s'en sortir et on va toujours
imaginer que marseille sort de
l'histoire de france
on va toujours l'imaginer mais marseille
est dans l'histoire de france sera
prononcée dans l'histoire de phrases et
on a bien intéressant d'y rester donc on
ne veut pas on ne veut pas être
caricaturé et être considérés comme des
rebelles
on veut appliquer la loi mais il faut
que l'état n'imagine pas qu'il suffit de
régner sur une population pour la rendre
obéissante
c'est pas comme ça qu'on résoudra une
telle crise jamais ce sera comme ça en
soit coque
oui il ya une crise de fait du
consentement qui est d'autant plus forte
qu'elle ne repose pas comme parfois sur
des éléments subjectifs mais cette fois
réellement sur des éléments objectifs
tout le monde a pu constater l'inaction
deux du gouvernement pendant l'été d'une
certaine façon on a laissé le virus
allait se régénérer reprendre des forces
avec les rassemblements qui ont eu lieu
durant l'été et revenir d'autant plus
fort à la rentrée par le mélange qui
était totalement prévisible
donc il ya cette inaction là qui se paye
aujourd'hui
et puis il ya la médiocrité aussi qui
est celle de la de la politique
pratiquée je pense par exemple à skis à
ce qu'on a connu et ce qu'on connaît
encore avec les tests on voit bien que
sur le tester tracé isolé ce triptyque
que la explose dès le début dès lors que
le premier terme testés n'a plus de sens
puisque les tests les résultats arrivent
plusieurs jours après alors que ce n'est
plus le moment et donc on ne peut plus
tracé et donc on ne peut plus isolé donc
c'est toute la politique sanitaire du
gouvernement qui est mise qui est mise
en défaut et partant de là si on y
rajoute les mesures actuelles qui sont
rempli d'incohérences
regardez par exemple ce qu'on a entendu
sur sur les écoles depuis depuis jeudi
soir et sur les gymnases
les adultes ne peuvent pas aller dans
les gymnases mais les enfants pourrait
toujours y aller d'une certaine façon
les enfants seraient immunisés
mais finalement les enfants aujourd'hui
depuis samedi ne peuvent plus aller dans
les gymnases non plus sauf pour les
activités scolaires ou périscolaires
autrement dit les enfants sont immunisés
mais uniquement dans le cadre scolaire
et à l'école
tout ça n'a pas de sens les gens le
voient bien et donc les autres mesures
qui sont proposés comme celles qui ont
été annoncées pour marseille ne sont pas
acceptés par par la population et on
peut comprendre justement ce rejet mais
ayant en tête quand même qu'une crise du
consentement cache toujours une crise de
la légitimité et de ce point de vue là
le gouvernement est frappé de plein
fouet et martin oui je suis absolument
d'accord avec cela d'autant plus que il
ya quand même aussi des embouteillages
et un embouteillage de crise en fait
depuis le début de ce quinquennat et la
crise finalement ne fait pas très bon
ménage avec ce gouvernement qui n'arrive
pas à gérer ces crises et à y mettre
terme
c'est ça le problème donc ça a commencé
évidemment c'est la sphère benalla c'est
des retraites ou en outils
combien ça a été très bien travaillé en
amant combien il ya eu des concertations
des consultations dès que le texte
commence à sortir tout le monde dit mais
nous n'avons jamais été consultés et
concertée là dessus c'est l'assurance
chômage c'est là là là aujourd'hui
maintenant évidemment ce sont les gilets
jaunes vous rendez compte deux ans de
crise de gilles est jeune mais mais mais
c'est à afférents c'est effrayant et
aucun gouvernement est incapable à ce
point-là de gérer cela ça aurait pu
durer deux jours trois jours une semaine
il suffisait peut-être de rétropédaler
tout de suite mais non ça a coûté
finalement des centaines et des
centaines de millions d'euros
tout simplement parce que le
gouvernement n'a pas eu envie d'agir
tout de suite de collaborer avec sa
population
ça c'est vraiment problématique cette
espèce de nos capacités de ce
gouvernement est peut-être encore plus
du jupitérien emmanuel macron de de
vouloir parler finalement avec ses
citoyens et citoyennes et ils sas est
incompréhensible et c'est très compliqué
c'est pour ça effectivement comme ça a
été dit il ya une crise très forte aussi
de légitimité de ceux couverts
la légitimité des manuels maquereau en
plus tient à une énorme à un énorme coup
de com un énorme hold up électoral
certes andy à hold up démocratique
puisqu'il n'avait même jamais été élu
même pas comme conseiller municipal dans
une petite mairie dans une petite
commune aucune part donc il ya tout d'un
coup on se dit est ce que finalement ils
avaient la compétence de passer de
jamais élu un président ça c'est quand
même très problématique est donc
effectivement il ya un choc de confiance
qui aurait doit être rattrapé et ils
sont incapables de trouver et d'aller
chercher le chemin de ce choc de
confiance
j'en veux pour preuve évidemment macron
cet été mais j'en veux aussi pour preuve
on apparaître à l'heure donc le 1900 et
veyran est aussi évidemment jean castex
qui a géré un déconfinement en deux
temps trois mouvements qui est devenu
tout de suite premier ministre donc à
laisser le déconfinement on sait pas
trop à qui finalement et qui lui même
lors d'une émission récente de
télévision dit qu'il ne sait pas qu'il
ne voit plus personne que l'application
convient ne l'intéressent pas enfin 8
même avoue quelque chose qui relève de
l'incompétence
donc c'est très compliqué et on voit
aussi autre point problématique en
politique c'est gouverner c'est prévoir
c'est peut-être un peu banal de dire ça
mais on l'a dit et tout le monde l'a dit
sur ce plateau
tout le monde pouvait savoir ce qui
allait se passer en septembre
pourquoi le gouvernement n'a pas
anticiper correctement les choses tout
ça est très étonnant et il est un peu
effrayant d'autant plus que maintenant à
cette crise sanitaire s'ajoute en plus
évidemment la crise économique ça va
sans dire la crise sociale et maintenant
avec cette petite crise terroriste si je
puis dire qui est survenu il ya quelques
jours dans le coeur même de paris c'est
très compliqué avec un gouvernement qui
sape qui semble ne pas savoir gérer tout
cela
alors oui ce qui me frappe c'est qu'en
dépit du fait que on a beaucoup critiqué
emmanuel macron depuis son élection
après laffaire b dallas pendant les
gilets jaunes
il n'empêche que quand il a décrété le
confinement au mois de mars
tout le monde a obéi
une chose quand même inédite dans
l'histoire un truc dragons n'avaient
jamais fait une chose pareille
à aucun moment dans l'histoire de
l'humanité et tout le monde a obéi en
france où on est soi disant à 10 ans
line et on est tous ce pays
or qu'est ce que nous montre marseille
aujourd'hui c'est que dès qu'on reparle
de limiter nos libertés et notamment la
liberté d'entreprendre
là il se trouve que c'est marseille et
c'est marseille qui réagit mais je me
demande si demain il fallait de nouveau
confiné on peut l'imaginer ça arrive en
ce moment même à madrid
c'est arrivé en israël si on veut
confiner je me demande si le
gouvernement arriverait à se faire obéir
cette fois ci il s'est fait obéir sans
aucun problème en mars il se fait de
nouveau obéir à marseille puisque je les
dis tout le monde a obéi
même si certains disent attention dans
une semaine on obligera peut-être plus
enfin pour l'instant tout mon hobby mais
si on devait toujours confiné est-ce qu
on obéit ray est ce qu'on en oublierait
à ce gouvernement au gouvernement en
général quel qu'il soit c'est une
question françois cocq qu'en pensez vous
ce qui différencie le peuple français
emmanuel macron c'est que le peuple
français est un peuple profondément
politique est un peuple de raison quand
emmanuel macron n'ai jamais rien d'autre
qu'un vulgaire politiciens vous parliez
tout à l'heure du confinement du mois de
mars
le confinement du mois de mars était la
solution la solution d'intérêt général
et les françaises et les français l'ont
immédiatement compris comme cela et ce
qu'ils ont regretté
à ce moment là c'est que ce confinement
n'est pas eu lieu quelques jours plus
tôt ce qui aurait permis d'épargner bien
des vies et si ce confinement n'a pas eu
lieu plus tôt
c'est que monsieur macron était dans les
ces calculs politiciens parce qu'il
voulait absolument maintenir les
municipales alors même qu'ils savaient
qu'ils savaient même depuis des semaines
souvenez-vous de l'interview de madame
busin dans le monde qui dit que dès fin
janvier elle a prévenu l'exécutif delà
de la situation réelle et elle a dit que
les municipales par exemple ne
pourraient pas se tenir
on a bien vu à quel point le
gouvernement à retarder au maximum le
confinement à cause de cette de ce
rendez vous institutionnel électorale
que monsieur macron voulait absolument
absolument pas c'est donc je crois que
peuple lui est capable de réagir et s'il
ya besoin demain d'un autre confinement
parce que la situation l'exigé
les françaises et les français sauront
le faire par contre on n'oubliera pas
vous avez vu au printemps fleurir ce
hashtag sur les réseaux sociaux on
oubliera pas et c'est ça qui ressurgit
aujourd'hui pas plus tard que
en fin de semaine dernière il y avait
des auditions dans le cadre de
l'assemblée nationale où madame par lee
a été entendu et où on a appris que
madame par lee avait menti à propos des
militaires qui sont rentrés de one au
mois de janvier et qui n'ont pas été
testés alors qu'on le savait même depuis
le début qu'il n'avait pas été testée et
pourtant elle disait le contraire
on sait que monsieur virant depuis a
menti sur la question d'aider des
masques au mois deux ans au mois de mars
on sait que madame buffet elle même a
menti donc aujourd'hui il ya une
fragilité dans la parole publique encore
plus une fragilité dans la parole du
gouvernement et de monsieur macro et je
crois que la grande force de ce pays
c'est que malgré ça s'il ya une décision
nécessaire à prendre les françaises et
les français seront capable de
l'accepter
après encore faudrait-il que le débat
puisse être organisé et que le
gouvernement ne fasse pas oeuvre
d'autorité ou d'autoritarisme
comme ce qui fait de plus en plus avait
le bras ce oui je pense aussi que l'une
des raisons principales pour lesquelles
la situation est différente de celle du
mois de mars
c'est le nombre de morts on est à
l'orage a beaucoup mais d'une
cinquantaine de morts par jour on était
à près de mille morts par jour au moment
où le confinement a été décidé de là on
comprenait donc justement fond c'est pas
pour excuser le gouvernement
actuellement je vais y revenir mais on
comprend qu'il a justement il cherche à
apprendre de l'avant s'il a bien vu que
la courbe des contaminations même au
bout d'une vingtaine de jours à une
courbe des décès sur aussi de plus en
plus qu'on voit actuellement c'est des
personnes qui sont les plus menacés les
personnes âgées ou ayant des problèmes
médicaux qui sont le plus à risque de
décéder donc là au contraire je pense
que le gouvernement a fait preuve d'une
volonté de prévention
mais là où est la ou les dijonnais
d'accord notamment avec force cristiani
c'est ici ici pris comme un manche c'est
essayons un peu d'être positif comment
au fond comment on pourrait imaginer que
les choses auraient pu se passer
gouvernement aurait pu monde d'abord
dire comme l'a fait pareil
le font certains très bons médecins
comme par exemple arnaud fontanet
expliquer justement quelles sont les
causes de contamination assez
précisément par l'ofppt la contamination
à l'intérieur des ménages on sait que l
est l une des causes très importante
à new york le confinement été déclaré
quinze jours après 60 % des personnes
qui étaient atteintes qui venait d'être
à la tête n'était jamais sortie de chez
elle mais elle était elle-même jamais
sortie de chez elle mais des personnes
de leur famille pour des raisons souvent
importantes par exemple des infirmières
ou bien des livreurs étaient sortis de
chez eux et y avait contaminé leur
famille donc là le gouvernement à une
chose précise à dire ai dit voilà il ya
ce problème et arnaud fontanet l'a dit
hier notamment
mais ensuite la question c'est à dire
bah vous à marseille
le maire de marseille le maire des
communes des de marseille comment vous
allez traiter ce problème comment vous
allez en paix chéquier ou mini miss et
ses contagion à l'intérieur des foyers
dites nous comment vous allez faire et à
ce moment là on va continuer la
discussion et on nous fera confiance
dans ce cas là mais il ya peu de
dialogues or il pourrait être possible
il a été possible dans un certain nombre
de pays où ça nettement mieux marcher
donc la situation est assez mauvaise
faut quand même voir qu'on est
actuellement en france
un des cas les pires en europe
l'angleterre et puis avec l'espagne même
l'italie actuellement justement sentir
mieux parce que il ya sept
cette concertation il ya cette
explication des causes exacte de la
contamination je crois que c'est si on
veut un peu faire simplement au fond se
plaindre sur le passé mais faire oeuvre
de prédefin comment dire projeter un peu
dans l'avenir il me semble que c'est
cette manière na qui permettrait au
gouvernement de faire accepter sa
politique de sanitaires qui par ailleurs
est absolument essentiel alors dans les
pays où effectivement ils ont d'une
certaine manière résolue problème des la
contamination à l'intérieur des familles
c'est ceux qui ont pratiqué
le banc systématique des balades et même
des cas contacts c'est le cas de
singapour notamment qui est dans les
pays où il ya le moins de morts dus
coronavirus baisse est simple on isole
les malades et les cas contacts ce que
s'est toujours refusé à faire
la france à ma connaissance dernier mot
jean ce christianisme sur ce sujet nous
reste deux minutes une ligne pour vous
une minute pour saint martin je
souhaiterais tout de même dire à quel
point un début de crise les mairies qui
au fond d'eux de cette crise sanitaire
sans aucune munition nous étions
présents comme pour les gilet jaune
d'ailleurs nous avons apaisé des choses
pendant cette crise sanitaire
nous nous sommes battus dès le départ
lorsqu'il n'y avait pas de masque nous
sommes débrouillés pour que les
associations etc en en cause et en
construisent petit à petit nous avons
mis en place des tests
le conseil départemental le conseil
régional nous sommes arrivés localement
régionalement en faire en sorte de se
battre plutôt que de donner des
contraventions
pourquoi ne faisons nous pas confiance à
ces des locaux
c'est avec de tels comportements
dirigiste autoritaires comme yeux ont
produit les gilets jaunes et au pire les
électeurs extrême
donc à un moment donné il faudra bien se
rendre compte que les mères qui étaient
présents il faut pas ensuite les oublier
il faut pas ensuite les diriger les
considérer comme des simples guichets de
l'état donc ce que j'essaie de dire ce
que j'essaie de dire dans ce monde
d'ailleurs à oopa gravité mais ce taddei
ce monde prestigieux des idées des
essayistes démographe des historiens et
des grands politologues
moi qui ne suis qu'un simple mer un bhl
de terrain jeudi qu'à un moment donné si
le président de la république et le
premier ministre ne se rendent pas
compte que c'est ici en province mais
dans les autres provinces aussi que les
français vont trouver la force aussi de
réagir à ce moment là plutôt que
déconfinement moyenâgeux qui plombe
l'économie qui plombe le système social
mêmes humains
de la phrase peut être qu'à ce moment là
par un apaisement des choses par une une
présence un peu moins autoritaire mais
un peu plus démocratique on arrivera
peut-être à ce que la france réagit ce
mieux et que la décision d'interdiction
ne soit pas comprise comme une décision
médicale mais comme une décision
politique partagée par tous les français
dernier mot et il doit être très courts
vierges cd martin pardonnez-moi mais
l'émission se termine oui dans ce sens
là par exemple le drone qui a qui a
survolé le vieux portes le week-end
évidemment on ne donne pas des bourses
signent pour arriver à justement très la
créer la confiance et ce choc de
confiance nécessaire et puis cette série
d'incohérences surtout casse la
crédibilité aussi de la parole
scientifique on a peu parlé mais
aujourd'hui finalement tout cela et
toutes ces incohérences sont ouverts
aussi la porte à des théories du complot
a finalement le match ne sert à rien
finalement le virus n'existe peut-être
pas et cetera et donc là dessus aussi
le gouvernement doit impérativement se
reprendre en main
essayez de trouver une voie de
l'intelligence la voie du politique avec
un grand p
et pas de la politique politicienne mais
c'est tous les quatre d'avoir participé
à cette émission merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
entre 800 et 1000 tonnes de fuel se sont
déversés